in the previous lesson we performed a
simplified version of the rnac on the T
by info platform using the bowtie2t
mapping algorithm and RSM expression
table for genetic quantification now let
us perform rnac using a different set of
algorithms note that in this demo
pipeline also we are making use of
samples that were taken from humanized
mice with implanted tumors and consist
of two breast cancer subtypes that is
estrogen receptor positive and triple
negative our objective Remains the Same
here as well that is to generate gene
expression tables from the raw RNA
Secrets now let us click on the start
button to start the pipeline
recall that RNA seek analysis consists
of three major steps first we have the
pre-processing step that makes use of
the trinomatic
and PCR clean
also note that the functions of each of
the algorithms have been explained in
the pop-ups that show when you click on
that particular step so feel free to
browse through and learn at your peace
next let's click on high side 2 for
mapping all the transcripts
and finally HTC for quantifying Gene and
isoform apprentices
finally click on the end button
to end the pipeline and with that we
have built and rnac pipeline using
breast cancer samples in our next video
we will discuss what are the various
outputs and how to interpret them